meanwhile like joey's doing his best to
try and like convince me to not pick up
final fantasy online because uh
shut up
i'm doing this man a favor right now i'm
saving a life
so like last last week i off like me and
sydney off handily mentioned that we
maybe were interested in getting into
final fantasy online and joey like joey
perked up like we just mentioned that we
wanted to try crack or heroin or
something it's like god what did you
just say i think i think i'd be more
understanding if you said you wanted to
try heroin you know
i think that's i think doing heroin is
less life-threatening than final fantasy
14. dude like okay so i've had friends
uh
who have started it since day one yeah
right because they're big final fantasy
fans and and myself i was like okay i'll
i'll give it a go yeah but then i
remember but then like nam flashbacks
came back to me of like times where i
used to be like heavily addicted to mmos
right where like i would literally
what basically think of my three-day
streak with 13 sentinels but over the
course of like three years yeah right
right that was my experience with mmos
right that's why i didn't touch him
right and so i i tried it i did the
trial for final fantasy 14 because you
could do like a trial period without
actually purchasing the game okay um and
i did that really fun
but i was i stopped myself i was like no
i cannot i cannot do it you got some
willpower
i must i unlocked 100 of my brain to be
like joey you are not doing this now not
during the busiest year of your life
you are not you are not going to upload
for a year straight if you start this
right now yeah because i didn't notice
like i didn't know what you were doing
in the like the past
the days that you were playing 13
sentinels yeah but i did notice normally
joey uploads like every other day on his
joey channel yeah suddenly he stopped
uploading dude
i didn't even tweet for three days
i was like i was literally shut out from
the wall
the gamer thing where you wake up and
immediately start playing yeah you fall
asleep yeah three days oh that was
enough that was me for three days with
third time's a little bit boy but like
14. final fantasy 14 i'm i was like i'm
going to be that way i just know it
because i love final fantasy games i
love mmos and like everyone around me is
playing it as well right so i'm like
there's no there's no better feeling
than playing an mmo with a bunch of
mates yeah that's true obviously so i
was like no i have to stop myself i i
want to be a responsible adult
that actually does what he needs to do
and what's important
you need to be a functioning i need to
be a functioning member of society and
i'm not going to do this and then you
know and [ __ ] all my friends are like
so when are you going to start 14 john
i'm like stop it it's like a forbidden
thing i just don't go near them yeah i
just i know that they're they're bad for
everything in life exactly i'm sure i'll
have fun were you like into wow and i
was like
runescape
you know looking back i just think this
is this is insane i would just sit there
clicking on trees for eight hours right
and i'm like what is this yeah
i can't why did i do that
i'm so emotionally invested yeah like
don't get me wrong if i was a teenager
like now and 14 came out i'd be on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] every day but because
there's less i have less
responsibilities than i do now yeah
because when we did the runescape stream
uh like i remember i had a lot of fun
and then it dawned on me that whatever
we were doing was like like twice the
speed or like how how how much faster
was it like 20 yeah 20 yeah
it was like more than 10 times the speed
it was 20 times speed it was like yeah
it was like 20 10 or 20 xp yeah but it
took us a whole day just to get to one
single boss battle
welcome to runescape how long would that
take if they did we didn't have the xp
multiplayer probably
and also like a couple weeks yeah and
like in runescape as well i think like
the last few levels are like the
equivalent to the entire like levels
before yeah so like getting to like 95
and doing like to 99 is that the same as
getting to 95. literally man discovers
how much of a grind runescape people say
one piece fans have commitment like
well the thing was i think the thing
that made runescape so kind of
uh addictive is that you could kind of
just like
kind of hands off it but kind of not
like you could just kind of it's other
monitor [ __ ] you can just click i knew
people who would do that they would have
their normal life but always have
runescape on the other monitor and they
would be like kind of sounds like a
gacha game yeah
i'm just gonna yeah i'm just gonna
pretty much
shut you off they never had sanity or
anything yeah yeah yeah or uh what's the
other one though it's like playing arc
nights with unlimited sanity never ends
yeah it literally was like it's just a
it never stopped you yeah yeah i think
that's what made it so good never they
never tried to stop you right i feel
like people probably put more money in
because it wouldn't stop you but they
never had microsoft actions they just
had membership yeah yeah oh the good old
days
so yeah i'm doing everything in my power
right now to stop sydney from getting
into final fantasy 14 because you
shouldn't you should you shouldn't
i mean we were just like mildly curious
right we were just like we were just
like maybe maybe we'll look into this
and that's that's how every drug
addiction yeah yeah
we were just like curious we're just
like like mildly mildly curious um and
then we saw that it had gotten so
popular that they literally removed it
from the store because i remember we we
just tried to like download it so that
made you want to have to play yes yeah
yeah so when i say classic cinderella
if it's hard to get then he gets it even
so like sydney like mentions that she's
gonna try and download it and i'm like
i'm like downstairs playing like 13
sentinels or whatever and she's like god
i don't know what's wrong but i don't i
can't download it and i'm just like [ __ ]
it sydney come on come on
have you never downloaded a game before
sydney come on
and so i go up and i'm just like cindy
you press the download button and i'm
like trying to scroll down to find out
where the [ __ ] this download button is
i'm like is this the download button no
just goes into another another pop-up
and i'm like trying to like navigate
this site i like try to go on a steam
page doesn't give me a download button
so i'm like i'm like so confused and i
realized that they had to like take it
off the store
because their servers literally aren't
big yeah because the servers literally
are too small to handle the player
influx that came in with the new
expansion
this is square enix which is literally
one of the biggest [ __ ] games what's
so good about this expansion that like i
don't know but i don't know it's the
story i want to know
i've heard it's the story yeah and now
that and now and when we couldn't
download it i'm just like okay is there
any other way to download it so i start
researching to see if there's any other
way to download it because now i really
want to [ __ ] play it what are you
like hacking into the screen
i'm just like there must be a way they
couldn't have just
they couldn't have just taken the file
away surely there's a way to download
the file but like it's uh yeah you
literally can't download it you can't
buy it you can't any like it's it's the
only instance i've seen in the gaming
community where i've tried to give amani
company and they've refused to accept my
money
right it's a money company that's right
sorry i'm money money i've i've tried to
give a company my money yeah and uh they
refuse to accept here just let the
service be broken and still take the
money
yeah well yeah we'll definitely fix it
yeah so i've heard sales uh coming back
on the 25th of february so stop that no
of january sorry so uh that's that's uh
that's coming up so the [ __ ] reason
why 16's been delayed for like two years
is
yeah
when that game initially released the
final fantasy online that was
terrible yeah right they it was so bad
that they removed it and they built it
they built it up from scratch yeah again
and then the re-release just [ __ ]
exploded yeah well even when it released
that it wasn't that big was it i don't
think it was big but nowhere near as it
is
now it's like i can't escape it yeah
it's been it's been a game where i
remember like one or two people talking
about it wasn't like a massive explosion
but like slowly over time i just keep
hearing it more and more and more and
it's really it really just [ __ ]
exploded with this new and walker
expansion that's the name right in
walker yeah yeah yeah you know you know
i've been to a lot of like themed cafes
in japan but uh the most i've ever been
to one cafe is the [ __ ] final fantasy
14 cafe just because all my friends like
you want to go to the final fantasy 14
cafe again i'm like i don't even know
this game dude why are you why are you
dragging me into this
shut
up i yeah i don't know i mean i'm sure
it's a good game i'm just never going to
do it because i don't want to go it's a
good game i just you know have
responsibilities now
i mean i'm sure it's a good game and
i've just been looking for a new game to
get into because it's
like minesweeper minesweeper
you know like there's there's games like
jumping where you know i'll play it for
content but i also want a game where i
can just play you want comfort game
right yeah i want to i want to come for
game because once 13 sentinels gets
finished
i just i just i just don't know what i'm
going to do with my life yeah we grow
when we leave our comfort zone
we accomplish things
i think they climbed everest in their
comfort zone
you know what i would learn like right
now you know you know we just feel out
we fill that void with more work and i
would like to know what happens if we
just do something fun instead of filling
that void with it certainly not final
fantasy because i've never [ __ ] seen
you yeah trash case will be on hiatus
what the
like three specials this year what's
happening i don't want you to be the
togashi of trash taste all right like i
want you to be present and here
no
hiatuses he'll break their own like
he'll call in to unlike zoom and [ __ ]
i'm doing a raid right now but yeah i
can trash taste
if we can talk about final fantasy 14 oh
my god
how many uh how long were you oh yeah
yeah this yeah [ __ ] knobby this
[ __ ] was like you know how he
tried to convince me to play 14. he was
like they have mahjong in final fantasy
14. i'm like what do you think of some
kind of like [ __ ] like
poker like no one's playing
just because there's mahjong in the game
don't mean doesn't mean i'm going to be
like yes give it to me
wait what do you think i am but like
like you're the dog this is like the
cheese and the the hell swallow swallow
the pill
it's in a layer of cheese it's like
pavlov's dog from mahjong